I picture you eat your food like a bird
and David has to spit it into your mouth
how many times does that happen well she
doesn't chew it right yeah right I
definitely if I am having a salad it has
a lot of like you know when when you're
eating ice cream cookie dough ice cream
and you dig out like the cookie dough
pieces oh you dig out the ranch the
cheese or the egg or the chicken
whatever but I do also eat my salads
with a spoon I find that it's 200 I need
a salad with a spoon I do sir that
doesn't work it oh it does you just
don't get the leaves
okay sometimes you get a little bit of
leaf all right and then it's that's what
makes it a salad a little bit if you
were to go to
um what's that salad place I like SSG
sweet greens yeah I like sweet green
until they stopped having hummus because
I don't eat their salad dressing I put
it with hummus but you could have you
could um you could have the Esser salad
where you don't get any of the greens it
can be called The Leaf me alone
order your THC products from mood today
for twenty percent off your first order
and free gummies go to hellomood.com and
use promo code trash Tuesday that's
hellomood.com promo code trash Tuesday
for 20 off your order and free gummies
head to factorymeals.com trash50 and use
code trash50 to get 50 off that's code
trash50 at factormeals.com trash50 to
get 50 off hey sluggies
um I am so excited in two days it's my
birthday you can come see me doing my
one night only show in my favorite place
on Earth Earth Las Vegas Nevada come
party with me at Wise Guys July 20th all
proceeds are going directly into slots
so please support my habit you can then
see me the following weekend July 20th
and 29th in Greensville South Carolina
I'll be in Philadelphia August 11th and
12th Calgary August 27th and I'll be in
San Francisco Austin and a bunch of
other places in the fall go to
annieleterman.com shows I'll so my solo
podcast Annie wood you can always catch
on Thursdays I'll see you there hi guys
I'm so excited this week are my big
shows in New York City and all of them
are sold out except for the Sunday night
show
um that's this Sunday July 23rd at Joe's
Pub in New York you can get tickets at
Esther andice.com and after that I'll be
in Oxnard DC Boston Madison San Diego
Chicago Detroit and so much more you can
get tickets at estheronice.com and I
have a new podcast with Rick lastman
don't ask me why but it is fun you can
see that on YouTube and wherever you
listen to podcasts it's called Rick and
Esther have a time and that is exactly
what we do
thank you
[Music]
you walked in I feel pranked no no I
feel ugly
no because this colorful flowery person
isn't it I think it's a good I think
it's a good contrast
Rick second time in a row what's going
on first lingerie
um who sent me is this I feel like this
is low who sent me uh the text about
this
would you read the text you sent Pete oh
I also the idea that you thought he was
gonna show up in lingerie is show out
hey will you read the text that you sent
me with all the information please
I did not mention the BDSM theme all
right is he miked up I'm not
good I uh uh no Rick no kalila not me
Kyla I did not tell Rick about BDSM
because I knew he wouldn't do it
can you just at least play sub
yeah
um hello everybody my name is Mr
abeknali not abignally not habik Nally
but Epic Nail hey loser I'm The
Substitute Teacher
pull his pants down my dog is on um
steroids I'm sorry about your doctor my
dog is on steroids and um he peed on the
bed and didn't even realize it and he's
just he still live with Bobby
I know there's got to be a lot of pp on
there I know and I feel really bad and I
have to take him out like every hour and
a half
and anyways what were you guys up to
well as much as I really feel for your
dog emergency I actually think that
what's been going on here has been more
important okay
I feel like there's tension
and we need you to help it okay could
you explain the tension I think we're
okay I don't feel oh okay
I don't feel tension oh good okay good
never mind then I feel comfy
what tension do you feel
and why do you what and what type of
tension specifically are afraid could
fall out there once like a there's gonna
be like a fight over her wait a second I
do want to address one thing though Rick
that was news to me
maybe as of the New York trip is that
people think that you and I You're the
Reason Bobby and I broke up
to this I don't bring me into your drama
I didn't do it what can we try to trace
back why they would think that though
why is there any like hints of why that
rumor started there's so many rumors
about all the things I don't know but
but where would that be is that why
you've been is that why you've tried
them and sell that that you're not
attracted to white men
I was trying to yeah get them off the
scent a little bit all right so so I did
see a clip uh from I don't know which
one one of the tiger bellies that
somebody edited together
uh where it got like millions of views
yeah that did imply that like it like
stuff stuff that I was saying to Bobby
they edited it as if I was saying it to
you and then there was role-playing
stuff that the three of us were doing
where we were like like how do you hit
on a girl and dating and I was hitting
on like they were both playing
characters at a bar we were all doing it
and then they edited it so it looked
like I was only saying it to you and you
were saying it to me her costume is
growing by the way this is kind of crazy
well I'm really sorry you got dragged
into the Bobby breakup drama okay this
is a real Theory
any any it doesn't I get comments
okay I just thought I love you but I
thought maybe you'd be the most like
unlikely
um well not unlikely oh yeah do you know
what I mean that's how I see him too
okay I get this game now the most
unlikely why why Esther if I'm so much
like your lover why am I myself you guys
are very similar as I was saying like
upbringing wise I can tell you both have
like a healthy that's a cop-out yes I
have loving parents and he has loving
parents but a lot of people have loving
parents that aren't like me how is that
a cop-out though like that's not a
specific thing like you're talking about
our parents like well you're both Jewish
sure but what are the species well that
is a specific thing it's a specific kind
of Jewish too what kind
Esther has like half that yeah half
regular
wait there's but they're you're also
very different yeah but I I don't know
like just the thought that you pointed
out my glass looked like it was gonna
fall as something that Dave does like 12
times is that that they're alike or that
you just put teetered something on the
edge of a couch yeah it's everything
that we have in common things that we
are uncomfortable about you with no but
that's something but oh wait you're OCD
right I don't like this well take your
shoes off it's like it's because you
want people to take their shoes off I
think that
I think that people who don't have
obsessive-compulsive disorder could also
subscribe to the idea that I don't need
cigarette butts poop and dirt running
around Asian people do it right but that
all Asian people are just specifications
no shoes in the house it's just Korean
I know it's everyone
it's all yeah it's I think it's everyone
but I'm finding that like do you get
those camera switches when you do the
fun looks are you gonna okay do you look
always on you can I just say though I do
like how much you do in your podcast
you're very creative you do I like that
he's handling you guys take a note this
is my BDSM some people they talk dirty
to me I say get my camera switch no but
it's good it's good no try it on my face
well this may be a little personal Rick
but like well I probably don't want to
talk about it you will talk about it I
will do you not talk about personal
stuff I do have some Unwritten uh
boundaries do you want to write them for
us please or you want to just we'll find
them they're nice to say no yeah I mean
if you want to just have them
organically come out or do you want to
give us a list because I'm no I'm
learning boundaries right now really
yeah we'll get back to in a second one
of which I think we need to respect are
other people's that when they bring
something up we shouldn't go below the
line too long I'm so sorry go ahead
I don't even remember what I said
perfect so sometimes sometimes when
somebody says I have something you know
that's very personal and you don't want
to tell them you don't want to talk
about it you just go like this for a
little and be like what was that foreign
I didn't forget okay what is it um
I mean this is a BDSM episode so I think
that there's I don't even know what that
stands for bad doggies make
slime
except after e
so go ahead and is it okay that they
laughed at something I said I love them
too red
um okay you know what I want every time
I make a joke if we could just get a
pickup of that of that and just okay go
ahead I um
I guess this is made too personal of a
question but like you know are do you
find yourself more of like the dominant
type in the bedroom or are you somebody
who's like you know very like you know
equal or you mix it up or you like what
do you find yourself
what's the pillow Prince that would mean
you just kind of like lay it back and
let it happen
so Esther
yeah she's a pillow princess yeah she's
a pillow princess you know last time I
was on here I asked her question and she
never answered do you ever get [__] face
forward what is that first of all Define
Face Forward who's facing cut to that
clip are you gonna do it
right back who's facing forward because
I'm facing forward I know I'm saying is
anyone ever looking at your face while
it happens
while it happens yeah is that the proper
uh product thing what does your sex
identify as there's actually a way where
you can do it where you're both facing
each other but he still gets to look
away from me exactly right I'm sure he
found he and I would have that in common
as well
wait how does that work so oh it's like
kind of half sit up right and you're
this way but then he gets to turn his
crank his neck I think it's just
missionary with closed eyes I am a
little nervous to share this but I will
share it like oh lately like a big issue
has been and it's literally a mutual
issue but we both don't like each
other's breath
like by the time s happens yeah you know
I'm saying it's been a long day nobody's
really freshened up maybe we met we had
fajitas for dinner with a lot of grilled
onions and so maybe
excuse me uh would you like extra
grilled onions and Esther goes no
of course so
sometimes you know we we have a mutual
agreement to sort of that's so funny you
know I why don't you brush your teeth
yeah because I I actually can I have a
really good answer but first a word from
our sponsor
have you guys been able to get any
toothpaste sponsorships or do they
refuse for the Vester or if he is we
have some tongue scrapers that are
begging to be on the show oh you guys
should get Tums
anyway so
um what was the question why don't you
brush your teeth oh we're gonna share
something this is good because yes I
don't believe that my at least for me my
oral health and I do feel the same for
Dave I don't think it is a priority
issue no oh you think it's a gut issue I
think it's coming from inside the house
oh what's happening
yeah what's happening inside the house
well if you really I guess they'll just
keep spilling the tea
um wouldn't you say if it's you maybe
it's more spilling the beans
this one I do know about me because I
saw a doctor like 10 years ago when I
first moved to LA and a lot of comics
told me why haven't you gone to a doctor
in 10 years oh well
because they gave her this bad news I
have this thing called gastroparesis
where it comes from when you chew your
food to
no you don't you swallow your food too
fast everyone goes we know without
chewing it enough and so then the food
rots in your stomach and cause bad
breath but why don't you just chew
better I dude I try I tried it all I
really have how many times did you try
Esther I've given up okay well that's
just like how Bobby eats like chunks of
steak whole because he doesn't have any
um teeth in the back he doesn't so he
has to cut this like a horse suck on the
flavor why does it hold back
um you know he has the money to get
implants he's just like it's too much
Korean thing though isn't it don't they
they only have 18 teeth
TNT
I do have a question which Jews
I know you talk a lot about like how you
need to like a person's body smell is it
the same issue though for a breath like
because sometimes I wear it like yes
yeah absolutely a thousand percent I
mean I don't know if there's a stronger
pheromone
other than that I agree when somebody's
breath smells
um my lady in the morning her breath her
morning breath I like uh-huh I will
agree and that's
nothing's not helping these rumors
um I don't know if somebody else would
smell it and be like I don't like it I
mean like some people like cilantro some
people like Esther it's like 50 50.
but I like her breath and not only is
that a good thing because it means I
don't oh bad breath it's also like
[Music]
I want to smell that the opposite of
wanting to smell something would be
dating Esther what does she like your
morning breath yeah
yeah so I think that it's just a matter
of finding the person who likes your
flavor he's like kind of late to be
telling her though no but I think that
probably you and Dave probably do to an
extent right
maybe if you chewed more equally hating
each other's breath though does almost
feel like liking each other
I don't know I'm scared to like be too
personal then don't talk about yourself
not him you know what if you want to
hear more about that we'll be revealing
it on the Rick and Esther
I'll say something to him like your
breath is bad and every time I do he's
like yours is terrible so it is like a
very equal and he's probably just so
like if you told me my breath was bad it
would offend me too it would let's also
not
shame I mean everybody gets bad breath
sometimes yeah and I think it's good to
call that out yeah I think it's good I
want oh it's the opposite it's good to
call out people when they have bad
breath or there's ways of knowledge
because because
no that's sugar though and sugar will
make it worse there's ways of doing it
with tact
um how well I want to learn are you
Native American
the the idea of of telling somebody
their breath is bad but calling them out
like oh Esther [__] sucks it's like
if somebody has a booger in their nose
you could just be like Esther
yeah you know you do it you're good very
good
um you can always find one I want to
know if my breath is bad yeah I wouldn't
but I want to know like in a lineup of
like 10 people who my breath is good to
and who it's bad to and what their
person what their breath smells like
well there's like a chemistry um math I
think but I know what you're saying but
it's also mixed in with what did you eat
also I have changed toothbrushes um
listen I'm gonna get [__] beat up in
the comments and I'm not sure if what
I'm saying is something that is true or
not it's just something I subscribe to I
am staying away from fluoride in my
toothpaste light me up internet I'm
doing that why and with that because it
it I have some hormone stuff that I'm
trying to figure out and some people
fluoride could [__] with their hormones
yes if you have a lot of it but I'm
brushing my teeth a few times a day all
right you have um High female hormones
right I have very high testosterone and
my estrogen has been fluctuating right
and my quarter and my um uh prolactin
wait do you I do you menstruate
um
because you're talking like you do he
wouldn't wear that color pants if he did
that's true girls who menstruate she men
straight she's she's right here ow she
bleeds out
she's a free leader so with this
fluoride toothpaste or lack thereof it
limits the amount of toothpaste I could
choose from and I have found that a lot
of the fluoride free toothpastes don't
have the same
when you're done like
it doesn't have that same Vibe have you
tried bokeh
it's a fluoride free toothpaste that I
use uh I have not which one do you use
but are you recommend you the person who
says her own boyfriend can't even [__]
her facing forward because her breath is
so bad I'm gonna try Boca
yeah maybe get back on fluoride ask her
what if you just deodorant chewed and
huge fluoride you would maybe maybe our
numbers would go up
okay I made out with Annie and her your
breath is like chemically matched with
mine really her breath is really we have
a vibester yeah I would make out with
you guys made out for like a bit or you
guys are like out somewhere and you were
attracted each other what do you want to
know now um just on the just on the show
and I yeah your breath was so good for
me thank you I don't think we've
generally we've we maybe we packed but I
don't know I don't think Dave would like
it if you if Dave is like me I don't
think Dave would like it if you two made
out and I'm gonna speak for Dave right
now you guys shouldn't do that we didn't
say we would we I'm just saying sex is
not kissing it sounds almost like you
really want us to no if I wanted you to
believe me I would I would I wouldn't be
bringing it up so much I would really
hate if you two girls kiss right now
whether you're new to cannabis or an old
Pro denying them the products on the
market seem iffy at best and when you
want to relax iffy is the last way you
want to feel mood puts an end to guess
in games it's a hundred percent
federally legal Delta 8 and Delta 9 THC
you can have shipped straight to you I
think the best thing about mood is that
the experts at mood have tested and
tailored different strains for specific
moods so you can get an energized for
when you want to seize the day you can
get creative to get inspired and
mentally stimulated you can get focused
you know perfect for getting in the zone
and then they have other moods like
euphoric erotic sleepy chill social and
body Soother however you like to take
THC mood has you covered great for both
beginner and Veteran users they're great
tasting gummies classic flower
convenient pre-rolls and so much more
ready for a good time without the
guesswork order your THC products from
mood today and for 20 off your first
order and free gummies go to
hellomood.com news promo code trash
Tuesday that's hello m-o-o-d.com promo
code trash Tuesday for 20 off your order
and and freak that's right it's getting
juicy brought to you by simply spiked
okay we're talking gossip right now all
right honestly that's understand what
you just said to me I said that you need
to be a lesbian she needs me to start
she wants me to start I need you I need
the Same by the way but this is not a
joke why do I have to be the lead I
really learned in the past couple weeks
that you are the perfect lesbian and
you're gatekeeping your lesbianism from
all of us I'm saving it for Todd I make
him mangina I make him tough no you're
the hottest possible lesbian you're I
would dominate I would crush the next
Ruby Rose yeah Heroes no you'd be Shane
from The L Word I'd be ashamed like you
actually could be blonde blue-eyed chain
I'd be ashamed God were we not all in
love with Shane Shane was so hot
I like Shane but I also really like
Jenny Schechter because I saw myself in
her Insider
um okay wait so we actually asked our
fans for some gossip and I got some
stuff I want to share let's be real I
think our gossip's out no it's not no do
you think we have more gossip are you
kidding oh my gosh are you you're a
delusional you and I have between the
three of us so much in the tank
is that we haven't even dusted off poor
men they're like finally she stopped
talking about me and then I'm like
just kidding
okay so this is actually kind of
interesting like
let me just I want to know what you guys
think of this situation
I have a co-worker that is attached to
his wife at the hip anytime she's home
he wants to leave early and be with her
he hates closing shifts because of this
he just emailed everyone today asking to
switch shifts because he just has to go
with his wife to a party of for her
friends and no one is going to switch
because he goes home early every day
because he clocks in 20 minutes early
every day he's always sick or sad and
stays home with her it's [__] weird
my female co-workers and I all discuss
how much we would hate to have a partner
like that and then we enjoy our alone
time she I think she hates him just as
much really this sounds like someone who
might be slightly
um
anxious
now I have to say I literally just
called myself out today for this
whenever I'm at The Comedy Store and I
know Dave is home I rush home yeah and
Dave was like I don't know why you do
that and the only like I keep telling
you stay out late he literally does and
I'm like it is just this like internet
can I tell you from the other side of
that where it's just people trying to
hang out with you at The Comedy Store
and you're just leaving you doing that
to Lisa the other day was the greatest
thing this is some gossip Lisa Traeger
was we were all talking to Esther and
you get your little moment with Esther
and you're like think it's gonna keep
going because it's just like the tip of
the like gossip iceberg
and then Esther just starts walking to
her car and like whoa what because like
you're not even gonna stay up and I was
like haha it's not just me okay I can't
tell you how many times this girl's left
me mid-sentence because I chased you
down the sidewalk I've chased you I know
I chased after a car I am this guy where
I rush home but if Dave is out of the
casino with your platonic lover Jean
yeah I will stay I will hang and do you
know how much Todd would like to be
involved in that by the way the casino
oh he's more than welcome I think what
if all of our boys went to the casino
you know Bobby was an exe this is Gossip
Bobby was not allowed to go to the
casino with Jean and Dave actually makes
sense and also he shouldn't be allowed
he's the worst Gambler he's not helpful
yeah he's not one time we were um I
think it was like Hard Rock somewhere in
like Florida we were in Florida
somewhere we were at a casino I've never
seen someone lose that much money so
fast I spent this is in Florida I spent
the next
three hours doing everything I could to
win the money back I stay at the
blackjack table and mind you I don't
gamble a lot but I won you pretended you
worked there you took tips
but I won the money back from um for him
because I was just like this cannot be
like I cannot believe you lost that in
like 30 minutes there's something about
watching someone who has money lose
money fast that makes me so excited it
gets me through like a fear that I have
but it's through someone else I was I
was at a casino once with the Hannibal
Buress and this was when I was like
living in my car broke like barely had
money like was so excited to be getting
this like paid feature gig hey who was
obsessed with you the most when you're
living in your car
me and who was shaming you though for
keeping your makeup in a plastic like
grocery bag look at you now you have a
sock a designer software
but um
yes still would rush home I'm like I
live in my car I'm in my house you don't
want to come over and hang out we can
listen to some music whatever you want
you want Taylor Swift you want Lana who
do you want I will say that like the
idea of going home and just hanging out
in pure comfort with someone you love is
really exciting no matter how long
you've been with them but where's your
yours coming from why do you need why do
you feel the need to go home today was
it anxiety do you really want to hang
out with him it's it's like all of it
it's like I just knowing that someone is
sitting there I'm like I want to rush
back and I don't know why because
sometimes I do go and then I don't even
we sit in our separate rooms it it makes
no sense and he's like that's crazy you
should stay as long as you want but I
will say about this person's with their
message is if a guy was always rushing
home to me I actually would not like it
it's kind of gross
uh let's just say this if Todd doesn't
pick up a FaceTime from me no no I
consider he's kidnapped my dog kidnapped
my dog where are you it's like he's
either gambling
or he's at the terrarium store he's like
getting a new gecko or something I know
now now I know the Tells but I no I like
I love being around Todd all the time
and when he's now that he's working and
I can't go on the road with it or you
can't go on the road with me I'm like
desperate desperate to get them I mean I
guess that's different because we're my
safe space is being at home with Dave
but we're not even in the same room that
is my oh I feel so that feels so good to
me when you guys are home are you always
like hanging are you separate no but he
always wants me to he has like his I
guess it's the aquarium room now um his
office and we have a TV in there and but
the only place for me to sit is like an
old gaming chair that's like back so I'm
like I'm like this and there's like cup
holders
and he always wants me to watch TV in
there but I'm like I want to like lay in
my bed I have the hospital but I can
like like it's perfect can I crack one
of these yes yes but kalila do you
um if a guy rushed home to you would you
be turned off
um okay so here's what I like I can only
speak for my last
um relationship because I haven't been
in anything that deep since
um I loved it when
I would randomly leave without like
telling Bobby or he would wake up and
then I wasn't home and I would look at
my phone and he'd be like where are you
Mommy
I need you and it made me feel so warm
inside but I did I I liked it when he
would go out to swingers or like to um
whatever Diner like after his sets at
The Comedy Store
um but he was really good about calling
me right after a set and saying like hey
I'm doing this with this specific person
and
um but sometimes he would come home at
three and that was okay with me I do
love good communication good phone calls
good keeping me in the loop of where you
are and stuff like that I remember one
time in college I was like I was dating
this guy and he went to Vegas for the
weekend like literally with his dad and
my dad was like
so he's been gone for two days and he
hasn't called you my dad was like my old
man dad was like he's not your boyfriend
like he like instilled in me if he
doesn't call you he's his dad's
boyfriend
my dad is my boyfriend
um yeah I don't know I feel like when
I'm at The Comedy Store if Todd doesn't
come with me we both know I'm gonna be
there until
the crack of dawn like he knows I'm not
coming home I can't I want to be with
him but I I respect you for that that's
amazingly you can go out and have fun
knowing he's home and you don't give a
[__] yeah I think that's good okay the
best feeling in the world is being in
like just a secure relationship yeah
there's implicit trust in the other
person and it's like you can do whatever
you want because like we are so sure
about each other yeah that is the
greatest feeling go fly baby go fly but
it took me years to be okay with that
because I wanted Dave to be jealous and
wonder where I was and I hated that he
was confident that must have annoyed him
so much yes he was like what the hell
um let's talk about simply spiked a
little bit because we're here chatting
for them a little bit
um so kalila what do you have there in
my hand is simply spiked mango peach
flavor I'm telling you guys like it's
been so hot here in LA
sweltering I know this is one of the
most refreshing drinks I have ever had I
take it in the shower with me
I blast my music I go in my like nothing
feels better than knowing you're gonna
step out for the night and you feel
really good about yourself and you take
one of these in the shower with you life
hack is so good fruit flavors right now
like it is not a summer if you're not
feeling that juicy Peach flavor it's
just my favorite too for the summer
especially I just think that if you're
for the summer fruit flavored drinks are
just it they're so refreshing
um and honestly like this is a great
thing to take at any party any summer
party you go to this is a hit yeah I
guarantee you it's definitely a good
present to bring simply spiked flavors
are crafted with five percent ABV and
five percent real fruit juice it's
summertime pick up a variety pack today
to try all four new fresh flavors
signature Peach that's our favorite
strawberry peach kiwi Peach and mango
peach go to drink simplyspike.com trash
Tuesday to find out how to get your
hands on new simply spiked Peach that's
drink
simplyspiked.com trash Tuesday flavored
beer naturally flavored with other
natural flavors simply spiko Milwaukee
Wisconsin celebrate responsibly simply
spiked is a trademark of the Simply
Orange Juice company and now we know if
you take a drink of it it's like
showering with kalila
[Music]
a little bit how serious is this that
the breath is but I do we I like his
body smell that's important for me I
will say this like people like his body
smell you just did
I had a partner who went full keto and
his breath turned like floral and shitty
and it was not a match for me anymore I
had a very big aversion to his scent
after his biochain now I'm not sure I
know what full keto means is that an
anime
and he's like carried around one of
those big swords like Cloud
but put him a picture people don't get
it do you like Todd's morning breath
shut up I do Todd your dog yes
does he like yours yes we love each
other wait I like my dog's breath
uh-oh more than your fiance's yeah do
you yeah oh is that why I named Donuts
my dogs have full-on garbage breath and
I'll kiss them like all day because
they're just like my babies right but I
mean not as like I don't feel sexual
towards him so that doesn't count do you
know what I mean yeah but like for me to
feel sexual towards somebody I really
really have to like
um everything about their scent and even
if it's maybe stronger for somebody like
their Bo might not someone would be like
oh like I hate that scent I'm probably
obsessed with her BL and I'll probably
stick my head in there and inhale deeply
a couple times a day
okay I'm uh I'll shower tied up
sometimes though if he smells too bad
yeah they smell that bad Todd's yeah
okay this yeah I've told Todd to throw a
throw a toothbrush in there same so I've
I've don't have a problem telling like
when I was in Bobby just be like hey go
brush your teeth because he either just
Vaped he ate you know whatever greasy
food hate and the combo is not good I
don't like Vape breath so I'm like
before we make out can you please go
don't like
vaping and smoking and I'm not talking
about even in a sexual sense I just I'm
very turned off by by it yeah it's very
unhealthy it is tough even like with now
that Bobby dips it not like we're
supposed to make it now oh he dips he
dips a lot so I'm like oh my God
yeah you dip I dip you dip uh but he
didn't have a scent he doesn't have a
natural body so he doesn't sweat his
armpits don't smell I mean Vape is it's
it's still bad for you I know what I'm
saying is like
um it's better though I it was hard for
me to even read it smells less bad too
yeah it does the what cigarettes are
Vapes it's like the baby doesn't it
doesn't smell as bad but it's still it's
not great it's not great but my
boyfriend's family is like a whole
vaping family they all used to smoke
cigarettes now they Vape his brother
makes like has a whole YouTube channel
where he makes Vape recipes and stuff
he's like Rich all Faith oh [__] I've
never heard of a vaping family they're a
vape family movie what what in New
Jersey
go to Toms River we Rick what is wrong
with your hormones like how did you know
because I never heard hear guys talk
about their hormones this is a very
female issue having it well you know I
feel very strongly about hormones uh you
and I actually had a discussion on the
phone about this I don't know if you
remember about
the morning after pill oh yeah um I have
very strong feelings on things that
adjust people's hormones I uh was having
panic attacks I know
and uh I see a lot of doctors uh
and uh I just I was get I didn't know
what was wrong my doctors didn't know it
was wrong and I experimented with a lot
of things foods and
went and got you know met with an
endocrinologist and I didn't know that
that was an issue but
uh I found out that my testosterone was
above what it even I don't even know
what it is it's higher than the 1500
that it goes to and at the time a
estrogen was really high and then my
estrogen went back here and then here
um
I know that I'm very sensitive to
cortisol spikes and get like I'm very in
touch with like
I've become very in touch with
when I feel a certain way how much of it
is chemical
um yeah that's what I'm working on too
low blood sugar even I made sure to have
a hard-boiled egg before I came here
um a good snack and uh not if you're
hypoglycemic
yeah I think that's not a fast sugar
um uh I take uh uh I find that in the
mornings I don't normally eat breakfast
I don't find I just don't but when I
have coffee I need to have something in
my body so I like to start the day with
at least a little protein yes because
that will prevent a cortisol Spike right
um I don't know if that's cortisol or
sometimes I don't know the difference
between cortisol and adrenaline I just
know that I am super sensitive to my
things and my feelings and uh
yeah my hormones I'm still trying to
figure out I have a meeting with uh
geneticists and I just what is that
these doctors what is the end of all
right I've heard of these doctors to get
you to feel a little bit more like um
like calibrated or is it because you're
trying to have a baby so I'm also
looking into that stuff as well
um
you guys don't have your headphones on
but there's some it's gonna be it's me
and you you keep looking at me it's what
is it leather something yeah it's the
leather but I'm just adjusting my mic
okay Rick I swear to God
I swear to God what you're in close
proximity to me we might I'm gonna throw
hands honest to God honest to goodness
if you hit me
I I would I would hit you back
I would I would hit you back and I would
hit you in the stomach hard or I can't
breathe because of this [__] course
and I would say
I'm pressing charges unless you let me
post the clip
that's my clip
now um the end goal is to better
understand why is this just what it is
or is there a better version is there
something that is doing this to me I do
I have been uh learning and working on
my own self-soothing practices and
that's great but do I need to implement
them as strongly if I could better
control the hormones of my body or is
this just what it is can you do some of
the self-soothing ones on me right now
it's self-soothing oh yeah I guess we
need a tongue scraper it did look a
little
it matches it matches the but we've
talked about that yeah
um that's just maybe if you chewed more
do you are you sweaty do you like sweat
a lot from stress and stuff I think I
mean I I've never noticed I sweat more
or less than the average athlete
um and then you're lucky if you have
high testosterone usually you go there's
a bald guys usually have high
testosterone right it depends if it
turns into DHT
um is that no DHE is that right yeah
um it's it depends everyone is is
different more or less susceptible
uh what would you do if you were bald
would you get hair implants
yeah really yeah because you're an actor
or just because because I would I would
probably just feel insecure about it
your dad is good here my dad my dad my
dad has better hair than my dad's hair
is his his forehead is like a thumbnail
it's it's a it's insane
my dad's hair it looks looks like like
George Lopez you know just like eyes
eyebrows hair just [__] Mane My
dancer is amazing
I love my dad so much that's cool where
would you get him I know I love my
parents too is it rude to ask a guy who
you see like starting to ball be like
hey like maybe save your pennies because
like I like hair and I would love for
you to keep your daddy's room to do it
that way again we were talking about
that okay tell me how oh by the way tell
me how
they have bad breath you never got to
that sure
um also and I don't want to be rude but
I could use this as an opportunity it's
not that big of a deal I know that you
were running late for something
lipstick on my teeth your breath sound
like well maybe one of them oh shut up
that's how I would do it like that
that's horrible that hurt my feelings
and you know what then now I know I
won't tell you that your breath is bad
yeah but how would you like it to me
she'll set it on a mic in front of them
but she he doesn't I was doing an acting
I'm saying you asked him and he was just
answering you said how would I do it I
was showing okay
all three of us all right I'll I'll show
you how to do it on a podcast ABC you're
all gonna turn and you tell us to do the
best you go first great
um real quick tell me the truth can you
will you edit this out
okay uh not coincidentally but your
breath is a little bad I don't really
care that much but if you want a mentor
to go do something
um and come back in right after she said
ABC a rick you go first and then we take
that why would but why wouldn't but why
would it matter like if you're on the
podcast with her why would it matter to
tell her during the podcast I just did
they're not really editing that out no I
know I know but I'm just saying as this
role play I'm saying but like in that
scenario while you're in the middle of
like a podcast you don't need to tell
her that because somebody might be
embarrassed
I would say like after if it's like this
yeah it's like after the show I'd be if
you were like I'm going out to do
something I'd be like all right before
maybe you should
your breath is a little bit rough a
little ripe yes I feel like afterwards
like if I'm helping up for something
else you're going to do but I wouldn't
need to do it I mean I know you were
doing for the sake of the thing but yeah
I didn't like yours as much I like it
might look better your turn
can I kiss you real quick
[Laughter]
he's like let me make your breath worse
just I'm
not doing anything Esther's talking okay
so um hey koyla uh I deal with this a
lot I just want you to know
I think your breath might be bad but um
it's not as bad as mine I can hear your
breath right now
start over
it's too serious yours is too serious
Annie's is more casual Annie says you're
just like wait wait don't go don't go
like let me help you out real quick I'll
be like like like a little bit like fun
[__] yeah yeah well I think but I know
I know you I'd be like oh my God I think
I wouldn't tell someone like if I don't
know them that way I wouldn't tell them
yeah that's a that's a that's something
that's that's a dance that I've had to
learn learn how to how to choreograph
myself I sometimes like feel like my
instinct used to be if I would want to
know I'll if I would tell the person and
I found myself in situations where I
don't know the other person and uh and
one of the one of the rules I've set for
myself is I don't know everybody my
truth and that could translate into many
different ways and I've had to censor
myself and I still feel bad like
in this arbitrary example there could be
someone I don't really know that much
and their brother's horrible and I'll
walk away not having told them which I
think was the right thing and still feel
like oh that was so shitty to me
but you sometimes you tell it and they
can't hear it yeah and I don't want to
carry that low sometimes it's like if
you have to work in close proximity to
people right let's say you're a
caretaker like I do think it is your
responsibility to make sure that your
breath is as good as it can be if you're
face to face with someone it's only
polite I've had to tell people that
their perfume is too strong when I work
with them I think that's okay yeah
because a lot of that's not really over
that's right also here's a quick little
PSA you guys have 50 men so here's for
the 50 women that want a guy's point of
view we don't want you to wear perfume
we don't like it it doesn't smell good
it smells like poison it's a chemical
now if you found a way to spray one time
and walk through it where we get close
to you and we go is that that could work
nobody nobody wants it I think you're
wrong nope I feel that way about Cologne
I think guys in the comments guys in the
comments right if you like women that
wear perfume what about perfume like you
know when she the smell of her shampoo
after it's water if it's a good smell
sure but listen let we're talking about
pheromones what are you hiding
a lot
I actually don't wear perfume and I'm
probably the only person you also don't
wear deodorant and I don't think you
would smell better with perfume I think
you feel better with a shower or you do
wear deodorant I wear deodorant that
doesn't work yeah sometimes I smell a
hoagie situation on me yeah I smelt you
oh yeah yeah I know but I'm all for I
get why you don't want to wear deodorant
but there's natural deodorants at work
um yeah I think perfume though it could
smell good
like to you when it's on the per it's
just
it's distracting I I don't think you
speak for all men though of course not
you sounded really really like well you
know yeah I got a strong point of view
and I'm selling it from I'll see this
there's some men who'd overdo it with a
cologne where I'm completely repulsed by
it and there are some men where like the
cologne sits with their body chemistry
really well and I am just so enamored by
it there's a Code but it's got to be a
very light amount there's a cologne that
Bobby wears that I hate oh no that's
intentional I absolutely hate it it's
something and it's not like and it's all
of them but it's it's such a weird
wearing cologne intentionally to repel
yes
but to repel everyone so what he doesn't
want is you smell good he doesn't want
that he wants people's reaction to be
like what the [__] is that is it like a
burning piece of wood like when I walk
around with headphones even if I'm not
listening to something so people don't
talk to me similarly maybe no but why
does he do that because he wants to
smell he calls it he wants to smell like
the future he doesn't want to smell like
every other boy he wants to smell like a
bird you still want to smell like Wiz
Khalifa
so that's his thing so like that some of
the stuff that he wears is so strong I
don't love it if I understood it
but I respect what is what happens but I
wasn't laughing I just didn't understand
it's okay it's a future and Wiz Khalifa
are both musicians oh okay I gotta know
and I'll say it they're both black there
sorry
and he is speaking for all men okay
speaking for all black men
we don't want your perfume you don't
want any cologne on any oh my God like I
actually feel this I'm I almost am
scared to sound too mean but I feel bad
for any man that wears cologne I'm like
I think it's so gross I feel bad I'm
like you must feel low status in society
like it's like we're talking about an
opinion on senses and instead judging
the person yeah okay that's my take how
I
ugly female I identify I relate I think
you're female
so you're not either I also want to say
on here because we bust us
you're not ugly you're really really
pretty really yeah sure say that what do
you say more we think you're pretty and
you're funny and what you thinking
you're ugly is like one of the things
that makes you hot
and you're not hot she has look at her
tits look at her tits
thanks Andy you're welcome sir yeah
don't speak about yourself that way you
could say that say that you're not a
pretty person it also doesn't but it
also doesn't like work in work anymore
yeah it was like
I couldn't identify as low status also
how about this a woman over 35 low
status over 35 really yeah honestly I
thought you were maybe 30. you look
amazing this is getting weird wow I
think there's some things coming don't
worry nothing's coming nothing ever
comes with you if you want more of those
left turns head on over to Rick and
Nester have a time
did your grandfather wear like cologne
or any sort of you assuming I knew my
grandfather is uh you scream I was Pals
with my grandfather more than anyone
I've ever my dad is grandpa but did he
ever wear like an actually yes my my
mom's uh my mom my grandfather and my
mom's side who's not my biological
grandfather but he wore Old Spice and
that does conjure up a positive memory
yeah but I just most colognes today that
we smell men today it's like ax or like
the things that Bobby it's just it
smells like chemicals and it's gross and
I do like a man smell I love a sweaty
underarm when like when Dave is dirty
like when he comes home from a fresh day
of golf yeah like you know you like that
smell just not the breath yes cover the
mouth yes there's a certain type of
smell that someone gets
um like it doesn't smell like body odor
it smells like the day like it in
Filipino we call it ozone you smell like
Otto
Otto just means like it smells like the
day like you've been working outside and
there's dirt in the Sun and that's good
or bad
also I don't like
um the smell of people's scalp scallops
that's you are so you're always fighting
us on this I like how clean of a
judgment that was I like but it's but
it's very dirty too it's because she
doesn't want to shower no no that's so
silly I like that bring that to our pod
you know what it is though Annie right
yes but Esther is like you should be
able to just not shower not bathe yeah
what is your what it's a scalp what it
smells about do you ever like smell
someone's hat you like the smell I love
the smell of my girl's scalp honest to
goodness love match
but it's a match but like I don't match
with other people this is what we're
talking about when you go to like a hot
yoga class and you go into the the
bathroom afterwards there are girls that
are just drying the [__] on their heads
into the bathroom and it is like it's
almost like you're okay they take like a
hair dryer and they dry their wet sweaty
scalp [__] criminal that's right
after the whole cycle after Soul cycle
class like mind you you're drenched
similar to Hot Yoga and then afterwards
instead of jumping in the shower and
maybe doing a little rinse you blow dry
the sweat on your head and it takes up
the smell takes up the whole room and I
literally want to kill some dry shampoo
at least something you guys are freaking
me out right now because you just helped
my memory figure out my favorite version
of me and all women which is After hot
yoga or a workout class your hair is
dripping sweat and then you just go
about your day and you let it dry and
then you have like this sweaty dry hair
so now add blow dryer to that you're
drying it that's fine that makes gets us
there faster no no for different reasons
blow drying your hair doesn't get you
where it would have gotten you had you
air dried it faster it's a completely
different thing I don't blow dry my hair
I like to dry my hair in a hat not for
the smell of course but because it helps
lock in the curls and if you want curls
head on over to Rick and Nestor have a
Time
foreign
are you too busy with summer plans to
cook but you want to make sure you're
eating well yeah why are you talking to
me like a robot also why are your
glasses down like that well with Factor
skip the extra trip to the grocery store
and The Chopping prepping and cleaning
up too while still getting the flavor
and nutritional quality look let the
people at home know what they're getting
not just read it factors
honest to goodness because they sponsor
my podcast it's really really good and
they cater to several different
Lifestyles from keto to calorie smart
vegan and veggie and protein plus if
you're on a high protein diet for your
muscles or your muscles factor is legit
the only way I've ever felt like I'm
eating restaurant quality meals at home
with a factor you can rest assured
you're making a sustainable Choice Rick
how so that well they offset a hundred
percent of their delivery emissions
Source a hundred percent renewable
electricity for their production sites
and offices and features sustainably
sourced Seafood in their meals they give
you 50 off by using
I have three words for you I am hungry
apple cinnamon pancakes head to
factormeals.com trash50 and use code
trash50 to get 50 off that's honestly
that's that
that's crazy that's code trash50 at
factormeals.com trash50 to get 50 off
trash 50 and yes we all want to have a
fun crazy wild summer and let's have
Factor feed us so that we can do that
let's have Esther stop cooking I've
never started let's just have facts
[Music]
yeah hairdresser I could tell wow it
looks like I don't gossip sir
people always you know what I do now
when hire people almost always gossip
you know what to do when they're doing
it I go I don't like that I don't like
the gossip do you really do that oh yeah
and what do they do they go okay what do
they gossip with you about though there
are other actors or other other people
other people on your
usually if I go to a hair person it's
because I'm I'm either getting my hair
cut that's the only time and I'm friends
with her or if it's on set somewhere and
then this is so there's always gossiping
about people well that's bad that's a
that's a bad sign if they're talking
[__] about someone else too every now
they're gonna drag something you said
over to someone else everybody talks
about people and everybody's talking
about me and everyone's talking about
you and you and you I don't want to be
part of it okay so I'm this I'm glad you
brought this up there's a coffee shop
near my house that I go to and there's a
guy that works there and for some reason
sometimes I'll just tell him [__] I
shouldn't tell him and are not like
shouldn't it's just like get him on the
Pod yeah I'm sure he'd love it but
a girl there's another comic that goes
there and he told me about her breakup
he goes I have to tell you some gossip
he goes so and so just went through a
breakup and I went oh my God he goes
don't tell her I go yeah right so I
immediately call I go dude the guy at
the coffee shop just told me about your
breakup and she's like are you [__]
kidding me
but then I go but then I go in and he
goes you told her I go this is a cycle
okay like it's inappropriate for her to
tell you her business it's inappropriate
for you but for you to think I'm not
going to tell her is apps I will 100
completely I had the same thing with the
masseuse but it's inappropriate I but I
have a problem that she has where I'm
like for some reason I'm like drinking
my coffee and I just tell this guy I go
why the [__] did I tell these guys this
masseuse told me a friend of mine like
all this stuff about her hormones and
like her trying to keep high
testosterone all this stuff and then I
was and then I told her my friend and
she was like why is she telling you that
because I'll tell you why
because you told the masseuse and you
told the Barista yeah no I
pulled their Unwritten boundaries
because they think whatever
what is it the feather the feather I
don't know I have no clue like once you
like the feather is out of the pillow no
that's not what I'm saying look up the
feathers are out of the pillow I believe
you I'm I believe I'm saying it wrong
but do you understand the analogy once
it's out no but I do think that's how I
feel I am a chatty [__] I'm a chatty no
I think when I'm a chatty [__] if I say
something I know that it's out it's
going to people I accept responses they
say the feathers are out of the you
can't put the feathers back in the
pillow look that up would you uh that's
where a cat out of the bag came right up
what no he typed in cat out of the bag
why was the cat in the bag why was the
cat in the
bags before we do a bit that's not going
to play for too long will you look good
no but this is not a bit finding out the
actual
you can't put the feathers back in the
pillow yeah
it's interesting that Andres knew about
the cat yeah there you go I still said
it oh she did what is it what is the
story about the gossip feather I mean
that's a quote
what's that the story is often told that
most is this
Philip no I mean I can't read any of
these words assigned for a woman for a
skin for spreading gossip anyway when
you say something to somebody it's now
everybody assume everybody in the world
knows it
[Music]
okay
find out why the cat was in the bag I
I think about gossiping though what is
it I'd like to say I'm saying it's a
fair origin story to want to understand
yes thank you I'll stare at each other
no Affair like like I don't know why the
cat is out of the bag I was gonna say
why was it my guess is if if that is a
metaphor for spilling the beans my guess
would be that once people saw the cat
you don't need to put it back in the bag
like we've already seen that what you
snuck in here was a cat oh you snuck it
in I see yeah still doesn't make that
much sense but I will say this this is
what I learned about God the pennies
down the toilet then
um so she wasn't here in my country
um the Philippines has no recorded
serial killers and they attribute what
about your family members no that's just
um they call that uh domestic Crime of
Passion okay yeah but your family
members are murderers yes yeah but like
obvious no serial killers not someone
who has gone months they kill within the
family yeah
but this is why the Philippines has no
serial killers is because we have a very
very
um efficient gossip culture we call it
like the chismosa culture where the moms
the aunties Everyone is always saying
each other's cheeseme yeah cheese maze
yeah but the Philippines was colonized
for 300 years in Spanish
culture is basically that like you
someone's gonna be busted before they're
able to commit their second murder
like we just don't have that because
everyone talks there your [__] is not
safe your secrets are not safe people
but in your analogy it would actually
makes people safe
yeah so there is an upside to being
gossipier being hey don't get mad at the
other person for saying the thing that
you decided to tell them unless they are
Inner Circle who was responsible for
really taking Bill Cosby down makeup
artists right people who worked in the
industry who talked I thought it was
Hannibal burst
he eventually talked about it like that
but I actually want to take that back
yeah I heard it was Bill Cosby himself
because he's the one that did it oh now
that he's the only one that's
responsible Forward Thinking I like that
and you're wearing a Cosby sweater so
it's perfect
did he wear Cardigans do you like it
just about it yeah poetic license join
in but did he wear Cardigans I think he
because if he did I'll stop wearing this
I hate what he did to those women I
thought he liked it you said he liked
what he did are you talking about us
check it out on Esther and Rick have a
time they discuss was Bill Cosby good or
bad
I heard he's going on tour again is that
crazy
who's going to open for him I mean Nelly
would you would you open for Bill I
would what did she say
you know if other prior open don't worry
the problem was we figured you would I
would open for him but I would do that I
would only he would only let me do it
once because I would go up there and I
would tell that SOB what you did to
those women was uncool man listen if I
want to sleep with a check what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna introduce
myself and hope she likes the smell of
my scalp because otherwise I don't need
to put something in her drink that's not
gonna get me off I could be having sex
with a beautiful woman and she says
she's enjoying it and I'm I'm thinking
yeah because I put something in your
drink that's not me I want to know that
you love me
you need them to say I love you first
honestly it helps me it helps do you
ever are you were you ever a one night
stand guy I have I have experimented
with it but I am not a one-man if you I
feel like if you have anxiety it's not
good right I have I did not like it yeah
I don't like
I don't
let's not even say what I don't like
because the list could go on I like
connection yeah I like a nice smelling
scalp I like good morning breath I like
her doggy I like liking somebody and
with that then like
to answer your question do you like to
be dominant or do we dominated okay he's
got a good memory baby
um that's private
hear about that
Rick's patreon yeah yeah
my I've done some episodes with my girl
on patreon we talk about that kind of
stuff so head on over to patreon.com
take your shoes off is your girlfriend
an actress where'd you meet her I don't
want to get into it really is that a
real boundary or joke boundary uh I
don't mind saying where we met but I
don't want to get too much into the
personal of the relationship so I'm just
gonna no will you Google nip it in the
bud I used to think when I used to cyber
sex as when I was 10 with other probably
10 year olds I bet you yeah right they
definitely were not 10. 47 years old we
talked about this in the last shoes I
think you had headaches where you and uh
I both admit that we uh went into chat
rooms and we performed pre-puberty we
probably found each other there and then
you pretended you were a girl I did guys
and girls but I found them really I
found that when I was a girl it what I'm
not making any shoes I'm telling you the
intention that I remember it was not
sexual to me it I it was not I was not
for me it wasn't understanding but but I
had found that that there were more I
mean it's obvious now guys looking to
talk to girls and girls can talk to the
guys and I found that I was able to get
in conversation with guys easier so what
I would do is uh I would pretend that
well if I was a guy and then it was
another guy whatever I would pretend
that my girlfriend was there with me so
then oh I'll let my girlfriend talk so
that would be whatever and then you
would just talk about stuff and it
wasn't sexual but it probably wasn't I
didn't realize were you like looking for
friends or you're just curious about
others it wasn't cyber sex it wasn't put
it in my bud you know it was like for
you for me it was you were still asking
age sex location and sending pictures
and I would look online for pictures of
girls and say this is me
would you be I was a girl and I used to
be a girl but I was also looking only
for girl pics so I don't really
understand how I have that forever so
maybe I was a guy I don't know but I uh
I I owe for the longest time thought
[__] meant but
what does it mean
so that's something that I can relate to
and not knowing the right words but yeah
I I my I was just desperate to get as
many pictures and I remember you'd have
to like wait for them to download like
they would I also wanted to see how guys
talk to girls I remember that and it
wasn't still it wasn't like how do you
pick up a girl it was just like oh it
was very voyeuristic like I'm seeing
something that I couldn't have otherwise
seen and I'm seeing this thing and I
just were like whoa do you have siblings
I have an older brother how much older
two and a half years and a half years I
mean at that when I was 10. do you guys
were you friends as kids no no he was
mean to you right well the way I
remember it to be fair he's not here to
defend himself but the way I remember it
yeah wait have you ever been effectively
catfished
in the early years of let's say Myspace
or probably
I also always assumed when I was talking
to somebody online
that like maybe this person is real okay
but so you've never actually gotten to
the end of it does that mean when you
finally meet somebody and you find out
their face yeah and then you yeah they
just disappear you've fallen in love the
feelings are real I've never fallen in
love but without meeting somebody I will
say at that age when I was doing that
engaging in that Behavior Uh there was
never got even close to a serious
conversation about meeting up God I fell
in deep really deep deep
um yeah so this was during Myspace and
um there was this Australian guy
we don't even know where he's from if
his Australian accent was real but I saw
that he was a mutual friend of my other
friend in Australia and I asked her the
I asked her the wrong question instead
of saying have you met this person in
real life I asked her do you know this
guy and she was like yeah I know him and
that's all and I didn't meaning I maybe
know him just online yes yes didn't
think I'm like oh then he's real and I
carried on a relationship with him
texting every day calling every day long
distance he would call me for about 10
months like letters of like we're in
love like we're gonna meet up in the
Philippines like all of this he would
send me care packages if anyone can find
this fight no one can find him now but I
remember he I remember he went by
Amorcito 888 I know I have a little
surprise for you
I know where the Philippines are
and one day I and he would always call
me because I didn't have money for like
international calls one day I was just
still like something is up so I called
him and I heard like a baby crying in
the background and he was like wait wait
why are you calling me don't call my
phone it was like really freaking weird
and all of all of his favorite songs
thank God I have like a great knowledge
for like 80s music so I was like oh my
God I love that song too but I remember
he was like my favorite song is um
Caribbean Queen which is a great [__]
80 song but he would then like he would
then reference like Old Heart songs
um how old were you guys
alone I never really cared until I met
you how old were you yeah
[Applause]
maybe he really was the guy
do you have a baby back in the day his
favorite heart is wrong what are you
talking about the ribs because she's
such there was a baby oh baby back ribs
that song have you guys seen the behind
the scenes of that song that went viral
a year ago it shows all the guys in the
room they're like my baby and it went
viral
so I don't know maybe you could use that
in this you know the heart song all I
want to do is make love to you all I
Wanna Do Is Make Love Not My Catfish no
I know I was pretending that was the
Boys and Men song which is another good
name for your podcast if you guys keep
doing this
boys free men
wait so
so who how old who was what who was this
person she was legal 20 maybe 19 20. wow
this was like four or five years ago now
I don't know anything like I he just
disappeared and then he wrote me like a
letter on my tickle me Hotmail at
Hotmail account and he was like Hey I
live in Florida now he was clearly
trying to like reconnect but I'm like
this person's not real I promise you
make a documentary meet up with him now
you still don't know who he is I don't
but his pictures were of this like
gorgeous like guy [__] so wait so after
the baby thing yeah that was it you had
a baby so I confronted him after hearing
the baby I'm like what the [__] was that
and he
um my sister was like hey something's
really fishy here like I think that
you're being like catfish I was like no
he's real I asked so and so and she's
met him and I went back to my friend I
was like wait you said you knew this guy
she's like no I know I'm online like
I've never met him in my life and that's
when I was like oh okay like I'm being
catfished and I was so humiliated and so
heartbroken because I had real feelings
for this guy so he probably lived in
Florida the whole time right or did he
have an Australia yeah he had an
Australian accent but he probably I'm
not kidding you but he's not a little
like this
all right then I really like listening
to Heart
foreign
I really do you do yeah what about
bananas
um I would make smoothies all the time
and I was starting to get these stomach
aches and I did an elimination thing and
I eliminated everything except FODMAP
diet I didn't use that for this okay I
eliminated bananas and blueberries and I
was fine and then I had to reintroduce
one I reintroduced blueberries that was
fine I'm assuming bananas were the issue
I don't know
hurts to say this because I love spinach
so much but if even a tiny leaflet
gets in my salad I am doubled over in
pain what explained to Esther what a
salad is
Mama what is salad I love spinach can't
have it
it's crazy people are still getting
catfished when you know about it yeah
if they can't FaceTime there's an issue
I'm Pro catfishing at this day and age
we all know that it's happening like we
all are educated enough to know it's
possible so at this point if it's
happening to you you want it you know
you are feel your everyone's educated
because you're educated and you're
projecting that it takes somebody to
learn a lesson and let's not that have
learned that lesson from it happening to
them let's have them learn that lesson
lesson from like hearing about it but
sometimes in life it's best to learn the
lesson for yourself yeah but wear a
seatbelt you know you don't have to
learn why you wear a seat belt the hard
way and that's why this emphasis is
brought to you by click it or ticket the
US government let's see how far she
could go
go ahead oh no she cut me off it's good
um so yeah sort of sweating the US
government your your mind the Gear's
turning how do I do [__] how do I do
bits I actually want to go back to this
catfishing thing don't you imagine a
world where let's say maybe you have an
injury maybe you're stuck at home and
you're bored and Lester's talking again
uh you can't do much and then Along
Comes a beautiful woman who's wanting to
chat with you on the internet you have
my attention yeah I thought subscriber
what's her body type well she's uh how
tall is she about five seven she has a
slick backed ponytail red lipstick uh
some BDSM tight leather clothes on and
golden kiss suntan skin how's her scalp
smell
very clean well then all I have to say
is hello
that's that's English how do you say an
Australian hello how do you say how do
you say Australian hello hello
Delilah has the most experience do you
remember uh hello
in Australia no I just remembered a
whole lot of like North
well let's say wouldn't you love to just
kind of lean back and lean into the
fantasy of this beautiful woman wanting
to talk to you online and having a great
relationship even if you never meet up
with her and it's never but it's not
it's not like you're justifying
something you're doing are you
catfishing people
you're not being honest I think what
you're describing is like going to a
strip club and buying into the fantasy
that this girl likes you and she is
getting paid and you're getting a lap
dance or whatever it is even that I
never connected to it's not a real
connection yeah I hate guys that think
they're better than strip clubs
you know what I'll let you out I'll go
ahead and express your point of view and
also try and be mindful of the Judgment
you're doing by saying better then as
opposed to me saying if it's not a real
connection it doesn't turn me on but I
don't I have trouble at strip clubs too
it's not it's like so hard I hand no
when I go and I'm like do you want to
just I can just give you money that
makes sense because of you you're a girl
that makes absolute suffering because
I'm not going there for the sexual
experience like I'm there to kind of
like support athleticism
[Applause]
I think strippers are athletes I'm there
for the show I think they're incredible
and a lot of times it really is like a
very I don't know like but you're
talking about their skill and their
entertainment sure I'm not judging what
they do I'm saying to have a girl dance
on you and give her 20 bucks and to feel
like yeah I want to buy into this
fantasy this girl likes me you don't
have to get a private dance you could
just be there what bothers you about
that
I've gone to a strip club three times in
my life once when like I don't know
before I even moved to California and
then two Bachelor parties and the times
I was there I just remember feeling like
first of all maybe it's just a stream
clothes I went to it's just it's just
gross what's gross about it just like I
don't know just it just feels there's
like wet money everywhere and it just
feels dirty it feels dirty it just feels
dirt there's just ugly guys and it feels
dirty
also oh my God what are you looking in
the mirror
good one Esther
I like the way Dave smells there's ugly
guys and ugly by the way nothing is
grosser than just a ton of ugly guys
ugly guys say that to kalila
the horny and you have a room full of um
throw my [__] into that mix so fast
wait are you gonna serve up and compete
with the strippers are you like oh
there's all these like ugly [__]
horny guys I want to finish this if the
sample is mostly ugly guys there is
something that brought them there
there's a reason that they all have that
thing in common there's like a
loneliness there's sure but good looking
guys I'm sure get lonely there's a
there's something about it where like
this is they feel and possibly it's true
this will satisfy their thing that thing
that they're trying to be satisfied is
connection with what they think is a
pretty girl and or some fun titties in
the face or whatever I don't connect
with that being connection I don't I
don't understand that like you know what
I'll say that to your point I do find it
creepy when men go there seeking some
type of like sexual anything usually the
guys I go there they're kind of just
like oh those girls are pretty it's a
whole fun situation with my friends but
if they're entertainment trying to get a
private dance and trying to really
connect that to me is a little bit like
give him 100 bucks do you jerk me off
yeah there was a there's a strip club in
Santa Fe there's like one strip club
when I lived there and it's so dark it's
all just like men really going to for
that yeah I'm not judging sex work I
want that to be if it's transactional
and you both agree to it sure but why do
you have to be there but what are we
we're tired are you standing there no
but but if if that is what Esther was
saying it's like you get to buy into
this fantasy that like oh you had a bad
day and now here's this person that
likes you that's not real
but why does I guess like a lot of
trying to be Pro catfish so she's
definitely Pro this right I forgot what
that was also a lot of stuff isn't real
and it's okay that is okay if you are
both on the same page for that but what
I was saying is the strip club if you
remember and we could go back in case I
said the difference is a strip club
they're both on the same page and I
wasn't negating them saying Oh that
makes more sense but when you're
catfishing for example if if you take a
guy to the club and he doesn't know it's
a strip club and you secretly buy a
dance for him whoa I was at the club
doing my thing you know I'm just being
Charming I'm best and then this girl
started dancing when she [__] wants
my Rod or whatever guys who go to strip
clubs talk like I don't know I was
completely
I'm getting like I think there's men
that go and they want to buy into the
fantasy I don't but they have to know
about it otherwise
hey I want you to pretend that you
didn't get paid so people I've seen did
you do that I've seen no I've seen
movies where there's Bachelor parties
and there's no strippers or anything
they just go out and they paid a girl to
[__] that died they're just scared of a
movie you saw it I think strip clubs are
fine if everybody is on the same page
catfishing is not because they're not on
the same page they might be on the same
page then it ain't catfishing sweetheart
title of the episode
laughs
but I know what you're saying I like I
like real connection I don't like a fake
thing and I think it's strip clubs are
like very weird and very fake but I
think even though everyone are buying
into it I'm like I'm buying into the
fakeness of it I know and I can lean in
the same when you go and see a Marvel
movie but you know what you're getting
into yeah ever go in there thinking it's
gonna how sexually satisfy me or my
friends and if my friends are going in
there for that like I'm gonna drop them
so fast but what um would you be a good
stripper do you think no horrible yeah
that sure would be good we play a little
royalty free games by the way you didn't
see by the way you didn't see a full
strip yeah I saw some royalty free dance
music by the way Rick trying to do that
that's fine but Rick fine I'm trying to
let you shine don't act like you don't
have two skills making other people
funny and dancing and I'm trying to give
you the second one Rick pretending that
the argument was always about catfishing
being no it is he totally I was so
understandable that was the origin I
don't want to go back to it but oh okay
wait wait wait yeah go back go back go
back please here he said he didn't like
strip clubs and then tried to pretend
where it started with me saying strip
clubs at least are on the same page
however I don't connect with a stripper
but you didn't I don't one of the
finaster for a second there was a guy
who created a a full that's an
Australian game
called The Church of love and what he
did was he would write women letters he
was uh right sorry men letters
pretending he was a woman okay and he
started creating he starts creating this
connection with women and then he
started hiring people and this is
obviously uh before the internet and
this is you defending her about this man
he created this huge company uh just
dedicated to uh have this correspondence
with women eventually this Camp was
found out he was put uh on trial and
then all these men went and defended him
on trial because they were so lonely
they found that this these fantasy
people they they okay I love that Esther
all the men is that hyperbole or they
found some men yes okay people no no
here I will say this as someone who has
been catfished I was coming out of a
really lonely relationship
time and each time that he said to me
that I cannot go on video cam
every time you said oh when I was like
hey let's video chat
um he when he said he could not do it
there was always suspicion there but I
wasn't willing to end it because I was
lonely I know of some women so yes you
might say I I know my husband's cheating
I just I don't want to know about it he
does his thing I'll do my thing because
if they found out they'd have to face it
here's his reality a lot of humans are
too uncomfortable facing their fears and
their traumas so they could get over
them so sure I'm sure there are some
people that don't want to know so they
get to reap the benefits of the
connection without the trauma and the
negative feelings of the being shut down
and lied to that doesn't mean it's a
healthy thing and that doesn't mean it's
something that we should be doing to
other people my name's Rick Glassman and
I say click it or ticket
where are your seatbelt in this country
I just watched I'm sorry go ahead I just
watched you
experience being played with instead of
against and just the [__] dopamine
but you have to but you have to bring
her down to give her this I don't think
so I think she'll find a way to bring
herself down
[Laughter]
look at her look at you're invited to
the attic and now you're the happiest
you
can't speak
I stir your ass that's the name of this
song Esther invited to the Attic
[Music]
and last night Dave played Uno with me
and I won around because it's based on
Randomness and not intelligence
I bet you you're intelligent what comes
after Uno
[Laughter]
oh God what a NAB workout thank you I
had a time yeah
Siesta case what is this tool by the way
that looks like micro needling
can I feel that does it feel good no yes
I bet you that feels good you want it
okay I see what this is is this meant to
be sexual or is this meant to score your
meat oh this is actually sharp I could
get into this score your meat you guys
ever could you ever um do any type of
like BDSM or be part of that Community
you think I like
um I've never done it seriously but I
think I could get into like people
pouring wax on me wait hot wax yeah
because I like when it hurts and then it
doesn't hurt right away oh that's just
like when they tweeze my shins that same
kind of like itchy kind of pain are you
basically saying not the same thing that
I squirt when I get my bikini wax
you don't like it imagine no it's a
night imagine somebody waxing you that
would be and then all of a sudden
uh that's got to have happened before
there's no way ought to have happened
before a girl gets waxed and then all of
a sudden she squirts maybe well if if
you have gotten waxed and squirted leave
comments uh comment uh Esther sucks and
if you haven't no no don't say that I'm
sorry Esther that was my instincts this
feels fully instincts
[__] good yeah I like that black eyes
with me while you do it we'll get this
look her face doesn't like okay
orgasm is different than squirting let's
see also why does it the color like it's
been it's a Brazilian wax have you guys
looked this up before
it was purple instead of blue
why is that possible
do you have BDSM Tendencies anybody out
there so what does it stand for you look
at what it stands for bondage bondage
um sadomasochism right BD what's the d
dick dominance dominance doministic
Nicholas that's so stupid but bondage uh
sex masochism I think is one
sadomasochism what does Sato mean as
insane what other different is there
different types of masochism that people
like I like [__] with masochism as
long as it's the kind of masochism I
enjoy [__] with maybe what like why
why the specificity Margaret Cho was
telling us that like some of these like
in the BDSM Community like I'm not maybe
not BDSM but like some of the Kinks that
people have like are really outrageous
she said that she saw a guy getting like
vacuum sealed like like a piece of steak
coming as he was getting vacuum sealed
like his whole body
yeah and he was like coming inside the
vacuum see that listen everyone has
their own Kinks and I think it's it's
it's unfair to judge them because it's
private it's theirs sure but also we're
human beings and there are some things
that are just so [__] weird to me so
weird that like does that Define the
btsm community you know like can you say
BTS um yeah oh the Army will get you
what army BDSM like
like if are there people in the BDSM
community that are like spokespers
spokespeople and they're like I do this
stuff and not be like hey we don't do
that you're making us all look crazy I
think they did that because Army Hammer
um said that oh this is actually like a
normal Kink within this community and I
think the community was like no yeah no
no not like when it's not what they like
to be cannibalized he's not really
eating people because a lot of the girls
stories that they shared allegations
whatever about their experience with
Armie Hammer was like that he was not
there was not consent he was doing it
without consent and the BDSM like
special people expertises were like well
I've seen I've seen 50 Shades of Gray I
know that you you need to like yeah so
that wasn't happening so people in that
Community were like that doesn't count
for what we do if someone is doing it
against their will
speaking against their will um I'd like
you to keep Army's Hammer name out your
[__] mouth
The Rock Against will
what
we won't be right back
we're never coming back sorry last
episode guys
why do you have the same glasses as them
are you trying to like morph in listen
Rick and I have a time is we're putting
a lot of eggs in that basket Frozen by
the way ladies then she got hers yeah
yeah I did a frozen embryos you should
sell them as merch no I want to give
them if I don't use them
if I don't use them I'm going to give
them to Josh Potter to fix his eye you
can use the stem cells oh he can wait a
minute then why not just give them to
him I want children get more eggs have
him
why I'm just joking I didn't know that
you were joking no but listen I um it's
so crazy has your girlfriend or have you
ever dated a girl that puts her eggs I
dated a girl who froze her eggs and it
was crazy right boy my arms tired but it
was crazy I have a lot of opinions on
hormones man it's it's been about well
yet I'm not well yet it's been over a
year you must have got your eggs
harvested a decade ago would you if I
paid the right price would you let me
eat one of your eggs for nutrients it
doesn't work way out of here so the eggs
are so small they're like this big
they're not that big yours are if your
eggs are anything like your ego I
imagine they're unhealthily large again
that is clicket
all right check out the Rick and Esther
have a Time Podcast I got to take your
shoes off podcast check out Annie Woods
check out tiger belly thank you so much
I got a loan together this is good check
out alone together on Hulu thank you so
much to Rick Richards glossman wait I
never know I never is yours I didn't
hear you you what is your full name
[Music]